al atp o también conocido como adenosín
trifosfato adenosina de hecho voy a
utilizar otro color es el adenosín
trifosfato adenosín trifosfato muy bien
al atp se le conoce
digamos comúnmente como la moneda
energética o la reserva energética de
los sistemas biológicos y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es hacernos una idea
de por qué se le considera de esta forma
y en principio parece digamos un nombre
muy complicado verdad digamos adenosina
trifosfato suena muy complicado y de
hecho si observamos su composición
molecular verdad parece también bastante
complicado pero digamos si vamos
observando parte por parte de todas las
partes que lo constituyen verdad se
vuelve un poco más entendible el porqué
es una reserva energética de los
sistemas biológicos verdad y lo primero
que haremos será digamos partir la
molécula en las partes
digamos son primero la de la adenosina
muy bien y la parte que sería el
trifosfato es decir los tres grupos
fosfato muy bien entonces digamos esta
primera parte esta primera parte que
tenemos aquí verdad es justamente la
adenosina y la adenosina está formada
por esta parte blanca que es una adenina
verdad unido con una ribosa muy bien y
de este otro lado tenemos los tres
grupos fosfato verdad de ahí el nombre
de trifosfato aquí tenemos un grupo
fosfato acá tenemos otro grupo fosfato y
finalmente aquí tenemos el tercer grupo
fosfato y para entender fácilmente cómo
es que se almacena la energía en los
sistemas biológicos veamos o más bien
vamos a representar la adenosina con
digamos vamos a escribirla como ave muy
bien simplemente ha de significar a
adenosina muy bien
y ésta estará unida a tres grupos
fosfato así que simplemente voy a
ponerlo digamos así con esta p y una
bolita que significa el grupo fosfato y
en ocasiones de hecho no sólo lo ponen
así sino que lo ponen como con un enlace
curvado verdad y esto significaría que
es un enlace que tiene mucha energía
entonces sería como algo así pero bueno
para evitar todas estas complicaciones
lo voy a poner como un simple enlace
solo hay que recordar que estos enlaces
en realidad son de alta energía muy bien
estos enlaces estos tres enlaces son de
alta energía son mucha energía ok y eso
significa esencialmente que los
electrones que se encuentran en estos
enlaces digamos pensemos en los
electrones que se encuentran en este
enlace verdad están en un estado de alta
energía muy bien y digamos este enlace
que tenemos aquí puede romperse y los
electrones van a mudarse a un estado más
cómodo es decir a un estado de baja
energía y cuando esto ocurre van a
liberar
justamente energía verdad y una forma de
pensarlo es digamos que si estoy yo en
un plano digamos a punto a punto de
saltar digamos que estoy en el borde y
tengo mucha energía potencial por esto
verdad cualquier cosa pequeña que me
modifique digamos puede hacerme caer y a
medida que caiga liberaré energía quizás
no sé por fricción con el aire o
eventualmente cuando golpee el suelo se
liberará energía verdad pero pero por
ejemplo si estoy sentado en un sillón
digamos que estoy en un estado de baja
energía y estoy cómodo quizás aquí no es
tan obvio como podría ir un estado de
energía más bajo verdad quizás lo que
podría ocurrir es que me quedé dormido
pero bueno esta vez digamos sólo una
metáfora de cómo pensar estos cambios de
energía verdad en esencia los electrones
de este enlace verdad que están en un
estado de alta energía digamos si si se
presentan las circunstancias adecuadas
pueden saltar del enlace hacia un estado
de energía más bajo y entonces se libera
y una posibilidad para que esto ocurra
es por ejemplo si a la molécula del atp
le agregamos una molécula de agua verdad
entonces obtendremos lo que se conoce
como la hidrólisis verdad se llevará a
cabo la hidrólisis y esencialmente lo
que va a pasar es que se va a liberar
uno de estos fosfatos verdad así que
simplemente tendremos una una adenosina
verdad unido ahora solo a dos grupos
fosfato solo dos grupos fosfato y que
justamente a éste se le conoce como a de
verdad sería a bp bp porque son dos
fosfatos el que tenemos aquí es atp atp
porque son tres fosfatos muy bien y qué
más ocurre en esta reacción bueno pues
tendremos un fosfato libre verdad ese
fosfato es el grupo fosfato se va a unir
se va a unir con un
h verdad del agua y por supuesto aquí
podríamos también tener un protón verdad
que es un h más y entonces estas son
digamos las sustancias que podemos
obtener al final pero esta no es la
parte importante en realidad la parte
importante verdad digamos es dado dado
que este enlace pensemos en este último
enlace dado que este enlace digamos los
electrones de este enlace cambian de un
estado cambian a un estado más bajo de
energía entonces se va a liberar energía
entonces de este lado de la reacción
vamos a tener energía liberada
entonces si nos fijamos de este lado
izquierdo de la reacción tenemos energía
almacenada aquí tendríamos energía
almacenada mientras que del lado derecho
tendríamos energía liberada verdad aquí
tendríamos energía liberada
aquí hay liberación de energía y a
medida que estudiamos bioquímica veremos
en repetidas ocasiones qué
la energía digamos se utiliza para ir de
una molécula de adp y un fosfato a atp
verdad trifosfato y eso lo que ocurre es
que almacena energía verdad y verás eso
por ejemplo en la fotosíntesis donde se
usa energía luminosa para eventualmente
acoplar el fosfato al pp y obtener atp
luego veremos también que cuando los
sistemas biológicos necesitan usar
energía entonces utilizarán el atp y
esencialmente la hidrólisis para liberar
esa energía y a veces esa energía se
puede usar para darnos e de generar
calor a veces para llevar a cabo otra
reacción cambiarnos en la conformación
de una proteína o en un fin puede ser
para cualquiera que sea el caso